it's super late how am I possibly gonna
have time to make a video today how
could I possibly spend all this time and
effort into making anything meaningful
for my millions of subscribers oh that's
right I'll make you laugh you lose get
the balloon money I'm tired so this is
gonna be hard this is gonna be really
difficult they're all a simple let's get
that air flow rate of Manan let's just
jump into it I bet you can't understand
a word in this video we're gonna do that
today guys good god it's like nothing
insane so number one thing you but
nothing here is music thank you serious
music okay no more no more this from the
bag jerks can't fix a VCR right that's
right Jam that's right Jane that's right
J that's right that's right J
that's right Jase that's right Jane
that's right J that's right Jane that's
right J that's right Jake that's right
[ __ ] that's right J that's right Jake
that's right jack that's right jack I'm
not even trying so pathetic I'm putting
on my AC while I communicate that's
right that's not much it's I just
realized it was getting hot and I think
I got the gist of it he's saying that's
right J although I really like red
letter media and he did make me chuckle
I am also kinda mine thank you for
asking that should be better now I'm
more comfortable how are you doing
76 million subscribers everybody this is
as good as it gets this is the peak that
you're getting all right 78 that's right
Jesus Christ
let's just keep jumping into it guys
Scott the nuclei dude have you lost a
challenge yet have you guys play this
game
[Music]
I know my devil like this
[Music]
that's great Myanmar's to have a drum
set each and we play on the switch it's
so fun
that's like legit an actual proper
representation of what it's like to play
that game what did that find wonderful
Madame say and I appreciate my face also
my wife and my girlfriend yeah I mean my
wife I mean my wife yeah so you see I'm
so I'm so sorry my wife is ill I love
you so much
is that real blessings fake lover looks
into the camera my wife and my
girlfriend yeah I mean my wife it looks
into the camera like back
[Music]
Jesus is confirmed for smash thank you
Jesus Christian Channel very cool oh my
god I am freaking out right now
I'm shaking I'm shaking Jesus Christ
it's match how long can I prolong this
joke to prolong this video let's just
keep jumping into it okay time has come
to cut my beard and honor a race by
svetlana
let's begin don't do it man
don't do it
[Applause]
thank you very happy that's great what
is this huh why do I always cut it why
do I always this is the Viking level
goddamn beautiful - just pure soy what
is this - hi I'm Gloria Borger hey Felix
can we get your comment on this article
bye
[Music]
how was that Cheeta Cheeta muy Manny
proposed a Donovan is RIE so she can eat
them last you over Yakima
[Applause]
I like you
oh I can't believe I like the bad so bad
yeah you know for once
unloose okay I actually lose the fact
how many episodes has it been I admit
defeat I lost I lost okay moving on
let's just keep jumping into it guys
mm-hm
science it's gonna be sands just play it
I already know it's coming did it at
date
[Music]
so lame what is the name of Thor's
hammer millet millet
Jonathan Jonathan come here Jonathan by
the power use a side hop to avoid enemy
attacks this will create an opening that
you can use what's this up was I
supposed to find this at the start of
the game oh my god
this is the tutorial I've done three out
of the four divine beasts and this is
the tutorial alright target the enemy
besides I do not know the necks all
right hold on target enemy are you
kidding me does this thing just want me
to just practice a jump that doesn't
want me to do anything else just really
wants to make sure I'm jumping I'm sorry
what now do you can charge attacks I
can't tell if this is set up for that
that's so funny oh my sights oh that's
great
crucial these skills crucial I already
lost at this point I don't care what the
hell is on there doesn't matter
80 in red hello madam I once give you
some free cash free cash fiver for you
no cash
oh that was a reaction I've seen that
good but I forgot Jesus Christ guess
some people don't like to be approached
this is why I have social anxiety what's
gonna happen nothing I can't believe I
fell for that meme I fell for the meme
guys gosh darn it okay then let's end it
here smash like if you enjoyed thank you
guys for one year of you laughs you lose
Wow it's been my pleasure honor and
privileged for you to smash like on this
video hope you guys enjoyed it and it
really means a lot to me that you
smashed like twice on this video thank
you guys so much love you guys so much
see you guys next year so much and I see
you guys so much goodbye so much